Thanks to the Great Courses Plus for sponsoring
this episode.
Hey Crazies.
You’ve been asking for a good solid video
on black holes for a while
and there’s a reason I waited until
now to do it.
I had to cover some relativity stuff first
or this video wouldn't have made any sense.
Anyway, here we go!
It seems pretty natural to start this at the
beginning.
No no! Too far!
Not the beginning of the universe, the beginning
of a black hole.
A black hole forms when you get enough mass
into a small enough volume
and the best mechanism the universe has for
that is gravity.
Say you’ve got a star with a sufficiently
large mass.
Anything greater than 20 times the mass of
our Sun ought to do it.
Now, not all of that mass is going to form
a black hole.
Only the stellar core will, which is only
about 3 times the mass of our Sun.
The other 17 solar masses are blasted into space by a supernova.
At the end of a large star’s life, the core
is mostly made of iron,
but it doesn’t stay iron for much longer.
The core’s own gravity collapses it into
a neutron star.
That’s a ball of neutrons about the size
of a small city.
Neutrons are capable of exerting some outward
pressure thanks to quantum mechanics,
but this thing is just too massive for it
to do any good.
The neutron star continues to collapse under
its own gravity.
Eventually, the mass is compressed into such
a small volume that
the space-time around the neutron star is
curved to an extreme.
A perfectly-black bubble forms around it called
an event horizon.
This is a black hole.
Except, it’s not actually a hole.
This graphic is not what a black hole looks
like.
Ignore these.
A black hole is a sphere.
It’s a ball.
But it’s so black, you can’t tell that
it’s three dimensional.
It just looks like a circle from all directions.
Black holes have been a part of general relativity
since it was published in 1915,
but the term “black hole” wasn't coined until the mid-1960s.
Black ball isn’t nearly as catchy, exciting,
or scary.
I mean, tell me what you think:
Black balls in space!
vs
Black holes in space!
Look, I’m not saying black holes aren’t
scary.
Because they are.
They’re terrifying!
But only because they let you get closer than
usual.
Once those outer layers of the star get blasted
away, the collapse
of the core has no effect on the gravity outside
the original core’s volume.
If anything is still orbiting, it will keep
orbiting.
Nothing is going to suddenly get sucked in
just because it’s a black hole now.
Black holes don’t suck!
All the weirdness that happens around a black
hole
happens inside the volume of the original
core.
As the core collapses, it makes more space
accessible around itself.
You can get a lot closer to that mass than
you could before.
Now, before we move forward, we’re going
to make a big assumption.
For simplicity, we’re going to assume this
black hole is not rotating.
Yes, I know that’s not very realistic.
But rotating black holes really deserve their
own video.
Making that assumption, the first thing you’re
going to notice
is a sphere of orbiting light, which we naturally
call a photon sphere.
Yeah, you heard me right!
Light.
The thing that always travels the straightest
path possible through space-time
can orbit the black hole at this place.
The diameter of this sphere is 1.5 times the
diameter of the event horizon.
That’s about 16.5 miles across for our 3
solar-mass black hole.
Outside that sphere, stable orbits are possible.
Inside, orbits are destined to collapse into
the black hole.
The next thing you’ll notice is that perfectly-black
and terrifying event horizon.
Let’s talk a little more about that.
The size of the event horizon is called the
Schwarzschild radius.
For our 3 solar-mass black hole, it’s about
5.5 miles.
Meaning it’s about 11 miles across,
which is a very small space to have 3 solar-masses
crammed into.
And, as far as general relativity is concerned,
this is the lower limit for the size of a
black hole.
The more mass you cram into a black hole,
the bigger the event horizon.
Black holes grow as they eat.
Why do they call it a horizon?
Excellent question! It's actually a very good name.
A horizon is a boundary we can’t see beyond.
Kind of like the horizon when you stand on
the Earth.
The curvature of the Earth has hidden those
places from view.
Likewise, an event horizon is a boundary hiding
events from view.
As in space-time events.
Yes, the same kind of events we’ve been
talking about in these relativity videos.
To the space-time diagram!
Right before the neutron star turns into a
black hole, it’s moving forward in time.
But these axes don’t belong to that neutron
star.
They belong to a distant observer, like maybe
us on or near the Earth.
To form a black hole, the neutron star must
collapse inside this boundary.
A boundary that will eventually be the event
horizon, but isn’t yet.
Speaking of which, once that event horizon
forms, we call that
the outside edge of black hole instead of the
matter still collapsing behind it.
Here’s why.
As the last bit of neutron star collapses
inside the boundary,
the event horizon comes into being.
Everything inside it is immediately separated
from the rest of the universe.
It’s no longer part of the normal flow of
time.
Once the event horizon forms, none of the
"now" that happens inside it
will ever be part of our "now."
A black hole is what it looks like when events
have been completely severed from the universe.
So, in a way, it's kind of like a hole.
It’s a piece of the universe that’s missing.
So what’s a black hole?
A black hole is a black spherical object with
the mass of at least 3 Suns.
That mass is so compressed and the space-time
around it so curved
that all events inside its horizon are forever
separated from the universe.
A black hole is a missing piece of space-time.
So, got any questions about black holes?
Please ask in the comments.
Thanks for liking and sharing this video.
Don’t forget to subscribe if you’d like
to keep up with us.
And until next time, remember, it’s OK to
be a little crazy.
Thanks to the Great Courses Plus for sponsoring
this episode of the Science Asylum.
The Great Courses Plus is a subscription video
service where you can learn about a wide range
of topics
like science, math, history, literature or
even how to cook, play chess, or become a
photographer.
You’ll get unlimited access to a huge library
of over ten thousand video lectures
taught by Ivy League professors and other
experts around the world.
New subjects, lectures, and professors added
every month.
I’ve been watching a series called "Mysteries
of Modern Physics: Time"
by physicist Sean Carroll.
It’s been helpful for some videos I’m
currently working on.
The Great Courses Plus is offering a free
trial to Science Asylum viewers.
Go to www dot the great courses plus dot com
slash science asylum
or click the link in the description below to start your free trial today.
Oh, one more thing.
Thanks to continued support from patrons on
Patreon,
I’ll be at VidCon next week.
If any of you are there and see me, don’t
hesitate to come up and say hi.
If you’re not, that’s cool.
I’m hoping to post a vlog about it in early
July.
Anyway, thanks for watching!